The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
BARTON ZWIEBACH: Let's begin.
So today's lecture will
deal with the subject
of squeeze states
and photon states.
And it all builds up from
the ideas of coherent states
that we were talking
about last time.
So let me begin by reminding
you about the few facts
that we had about
coherent states.
So a coherent state was
born by taking the ground
state of the harmonic
oscillator and displacing it
with a translation
operator some distance, x0.
And then we let
it go, and we saw
that this sort of wave function
would just move from the left
and to the right coherently,
without spreading out,
without changing shape.
It would move in a nice way.
Now, this was obtained with
a translation operator, which
was an exponential that had
on the exponent the momentum
operator.
But we realized eventually that
the reason it all works out
is because its exponential
of something that
depends on creation or
annihilation operators,
and we could do
something more general,
which was to use a
complex number, alpha,
and define a
displacement operator,
a more general one, that is
some linear combination of a
and a dagger with alpha and
the complex conjugate of alpha.
So this is only proportional to
the momentum if alpha is real,
but if alpha is not real,
that operator in the exponent
is not quite the momentum.
It's something that has a
bit of position as well.
So this is a more
general operator,
but on the other
hand, it's clear
that it's anti-Hermitian,
because if you
take the dagger of this
thing, this term becomes
that and that term
becomes this one,
each one with a change of sign.
So you're really with an
anti-Hermitian operator.
Therefore, the whole
operator is unitary
and you're acting with a
unitary operator on the vacuum.
And therefore, this state
is also well normalized
and represents a state
with some expectation
value of the position.
Just like a coherent state,
we moved it to the right
and it had some expectation
value of the position.
But this one also has
some expectation value
of the momentum.
So in fact, we realize that the
real part of alpha in this axis
was related to the expectation
value of the position divided
by to the 0.
So if you produce
a coherent state
with this value of alpha
in the complex alpha plane,
well, you go down and
that's the expectation value
of the position.
You go horizontally,
well, that's
the expectation value
of the momentum scaled
because this alpha is a
pure number, has no units.
So this x over square root
of 2 d0 and p d0 over h
bar have no units, and
that's how it should be.
So we learned also that the
annihilation operator acting
on this coherent state was
alpha times the coherent state.
So it's a very simple property.
That number, alpha,
is the eigenvalue
of the destruction operator.
Now, that's a one line
computation based on this,
or a two line computation maybe.
But it should be a computation
that is easy for you to do.
So make sure you
know how to get this
very quickly from
this definition.
So that's a coherent state.
And then the thing we
finished the lecture
with was with the time evolution
of this coherent state.
And the time evolution was that
as the state, alpha, in time
becomes the state alpha at time
t, it remains a coherent state
but the value of
alpha is changed.
In fact, the value
of alpha is changed
in such a way that you can just
imagine this thing rotating,
and rotating with
angular velocity, omega.
So this thing was
the coherent state,
e to the minus i omega t alpha.
So this whole complex number,
instead of being alpha,
is just this.
There's no comma t.
This is the time
development of the state.
And there was a phase here, e
to the minus i omega t over 2,
that was not very relevant.
But that's what the
state was doing in time.
So basically, that's
where we got last time.
Before I push on, do
you have any questions?
I did post the notes associated
to coherent states about half
an hour ago, so you have them.
You do have two problems
on coherent states
in this homework, so the
notes should help you.
But any questions
about this picture?
OK.
So I want to develop
it a little more
before starting
with squeeze states.
So here's what I
want to tell you.
And this is an intuition that
people have about these states.
Alpha is a complex number.
And you know, it's a
well-defined complex number.
But you know, this
is a coherent state,
so it's not a
position eigenstate.
It's not a momentum eigenstate.
It's not an energy eigenstate.
It has all kinds
of uncertainties.
It has uncertainties in
position, in momentum,
and in energy.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: On that complex plane
where you have the x and the p,
are those expectation values
of the position of momentum?
BARTON ZWIEBACH: Yes.
I think I wrote them
with expectation values
of the position of
momentum last time.
Yes.
So given alpha,
that number you get
is the expectation value
of position or expectation
value of momentum.
Correct.
So actually, this is
the expectation value
of the position,
but the position
is a little bit rounded.
Yeah, this is the expectation
value of the position.
It's a number.
But intuitively, this
is spread out a little.
The position is
not just one point.
This is a coherent state.
It looks like a
Gaussian wave function.
The momentum is also
spread out a little.
So in some sense, many people
draw this as a little blob.
And that blob represents
your intuition
that yes, the
expectation value is this
and the expectation
value is this,
but the position is, well,
somewhere around this thing
and somewhere around that stuff.
You can complain, this is very
hand wavy, but it's useful.
It's good to have that physical
picture that the state really
is some sort of blob here, not
that the expectation values are
not well defined, but rather
that it's something like this.
And I want to relate it to
an idea that comes along
with waves, and it's
important for what
we're going to be
doing later today.
If you have a wave with energy
e, and suppose your wave
is a light wave.
Light wave with energy e.
And it's described by,
say, A cosine omega t.
That's some component
of the electric field
or the magnetic
field for this wave.
It is like that.
Well, we've been talking
about energy time uncertainty,
and we know that unless we
make things very precise.
It's easy to get things wrong.
So I will first do
something fairly imprecise
to give you a feeling of
what people talk about,
and then we'll use this picture
to do it more precisely.
So if you have
this wave, the face
of this wave-- we'll
call it phi-- is omega t.
And if we are naive
there, the face
is divided by omega
is the error in time.
Now, this wave has energy E.
It has some number of photons.
So the energy, E, is the number
of photons times h bar omega.
N is equal to number of photons.
And again, we could say delta
E is delta N h bar omega,
and then substitute these
two relations into this
to see what we get.
Well, delta E is
delta N h bar omega.
Delta t is delta phi over omega.
This should be h bar over 2.
The omegas cancel,
the h bar cancels,
and you get delta N delta phi
is about 1, or 1 over 2 or 1
over square root of 2.
And that's, in
fact, the relation
that people do take
somewhat seriously,
if you have a wave
in quantum optics
and say, well, the uncertainty
in the number of photons
and the uncertainty in the
coherence of these photons,
the phases, if they're out of
phase, they're not coherent,
there's a relation of this kind.
And this derivation is
certainly pretty bad.
It's just not
precise because even
we started with this that is
not precise unless you really
explain what you
mean by delta t.
So let's see if we can make
some sense of this picture here.
So here we go.
I want to do a small
calculation first.
So let's see what we have.
In this coherent state, what
is the expectation value
of the number operator?
Expectation value of the
number operator in alpha.
Well, the number
operator in alpha,
you would do this a
dagger a in alpha.
These are easy to do because a
on alpha is alpha times alpha,
and if you dagger that
equation, a dagger on alpha
is alpha star.
So you get-- I'll go slowly--
alpha alpha star here,
and then you get alpha alpha.
And alpha has unit norm.
These are numbers, so
this is equal to length
of alpha squared.
So if this is a
harmonic oscillator,
the expectation value of the
number operator, in fact,
is the length squared
of this vector.
Now, how about N squared?
N squared is a little
more work because you
have alpha a dagger
a a dagger a alpha.
This one gives me
the factor you know,
this one gives me
the factor you know.
And therefore, we already
have alpha squared times alpha
a a dagger alpha.
And here, the a's
and the a daggers
are kind of in the
wrong order because I
know what a is on a ket,
but a is now on the bra.
And I know what a
dagger is on the bra,
but now a dagger is on the ket.
But the answer is simple.
You replace this
by the commutator
plus the reverse order.
So this is equal to the
commutator, which is 1,
plus the thing in
the reverse order.
And this is 1 plus
alpha squared.
So you have alpha squared
times 1 plus alpha squared,
and that's the expectation
value of N squared.
All that, because we're
actually interested in what
is delta N, the uncertainty
in N in the coherent state.
And that would be
this, square root
of this, which is alpha
to the fourth plus alpha
squared minus the square of
the expectation value, which
is minus alpha to the fourth.
And this is length of alpha.
So the uncertainty in N
is just length of alpha.
It happens to be the square root
of the expectation value of N.
So in fact, if you
think of this picture,
you're tempted to say,
oh, this represents
the number of excited
states that you have.
This length represents the
expectation value of N. No.
The expectation value of
N is this length squared.
This length represents
delta N in the picture.
So what else can we say?
Well, this picture is
useful because now, I
can be a little
more precise here.
This thing is rotating.
That is time evolution
of your coherent state.
Now, this thing
this rotating, but I
can ask now how wide this is.
So what is the uncertainty
in x in a coherent state?
Well, the uncertainty
in x in a coherent state
is the same as the uncertainty
of the ground state
because you just moved it.
Uncertainty doesn't change.
So the uncertainty,
delta x, is in fact
this quantity that we call
d0 over square root of 2.
That's the uncertainty delta
x, and the uncertainty delta p
is h bar over d0
square root of 2.
These are not hard to remember.
d0 is the length scale of
the harmonic oscillator,
so that's typically what
the uncertainty should be.
The square root of 2, yes,
it's hard to remember.
But delta p is this one.
And then the other
thing that you
know is that the product
should be h bar over 2,
so that is correct.
Now, look at this.
How big is this thing?
If the uncertainty in x is
d0 over square root of 2,
this width is about
how much, roughly?
Nobody?
This is the uncertainty in
x, d0 over square root of 2
in these units, if you move
the expectation value of x
plus the uncertainty of x over
2 and the other uncertainty
of x roughly.
This thing is d0 over
square root of 2,
so it represents
basically 1/2, because you
change the expectation
value of x by this amount,
and then this thing moves 1/2.
The size of this
is 1/2, roughly.
Could be 1/4 or could be
2, but it's roughly 1/2.
And the vertical one corresponds
to the uncertainty in momentum.
So intuitively, this is
h over square root v0,
so if you plug it in there,
this amount, p plus delta p,
you'll get 1/2 as well.
So in this plot-- yes?
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't
the width be 1
because the uncertainty
is the width
in one direction [INAUDIBLE]?
BARTON ZWIEBACH:
Well, the uncertainty
is neither the width in
one direction or not.
It's a Gaussian, so I
don't know where it stops.
This picture is not very
precise when I talk about this,
so let me leave it with
1/2 or something like that.
I don't think we can do better.
Now, there's also 1/2 here.
So finally, we get to something
that is kind of interesting.
If really the state in some
sense, in terms of x and p,
is spread here, and
this is moving around,
the face is a little ambiguous.
Because you would say,
well, the face is this one,
but well, you could go the whole
uncertainty that you go here.
The uncertainty in where
the coherent state is,
we could call the face here
delta phi in this picture.
We don't know where this state
is because it's a little blob.
We know the expectation
values where they are,
but the state itself
is a little imprecise.
So there's an angle here
in this diagram that
represents the face because this
is going with frequency omega
t.
So this is the face
as this goes around,
so this angle, delta
phi, is how much.
Well, if this is
1/2 and this is 1/2,
I'm going to assume that
this is 1/2 as well, or 1,
or something like that.
So it's 1 over this length.
That's the uncertainty.
But delta N, we calculated.
This is roughly.
And delta N we calculated,
and it's exactly alpha.
So delta phi delta N
is about 1 correctly.
And here, there is
at least a picture
of what the face uncertainty
is and why it originates.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you
tell me again how
the Gaussian relates
to the uncertainty?
BARTON ZWIEBACH: One second.
Let me see.
I've got one question first.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Can you explain one more time
where the 1/2's come from?
[INAUDIBLE] the graph.
I'm not sure why.
BARTON ZWIEBACH: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are you saying
that the width is 1/2, or is
that how high it is?
BARTON ZWIEBACH: The
width of this little ball.
AUDIENCE: So how does that
follow from the graph?
BARTON ZWIEBACH: It's
a little hand wavy,
but I'll say it like this.
I expect the
position, if measured,
to be between expectation
value of x plus minus delta x.
So if I'm going to measure
the position of something
in a state, the most likely
measurement that I will get
is the expectation value
of x, statistically,
after I repeat this many times.
But if I just
measure, I'm probably
going to get some number
between this and this.
So if you think of this
diagram not as the expectation
value of x in here,
but whatever you
got for x as you measured,
if you do 1,000 measurements,
you're going to get points
all over here in some region
because you measure
x in one case,
then you measure the momentum,
you get a plot of data,
and you measure them all.
And then suppose you're
doing it with x first.
You measure x and you say,
well, I get all kinds of values.
I don't know what
the momentum is,
but I get all kinds of values.
They're going to run all
over here between these two
positions.
So when I add to the expectation
value of x this thing,
when I want to see in
this graph, what it is,
I must divide by
square root of 2d.
So I divide by 1 over square
root of 2 d0 to see how it goes
and how I plot it in
this graph because these
are the units in this graph.
So if delta x is d0
over square root of 2,
I'm going to get some values
that go from the expectation
value of x up to 1/2
more and 1/2 less.
AUDIENCE: So it's
not actually 1/2.
It's actually 1/2 times
whatever that set amount.
BARTON ZWIEBACH:
Well, if I say this,
that you obtain between this and
that, then I should say it's 1.
Maybe I had in mind
that you sort of get
most things between
1/2 of delta x.
It's not terribly
precise, but it's
roughly this is the picture.
You measure the position,
you're going to get that.
Similarly, you decide
to measure momentum.
You don't measure
position, measure momentum,
and you're going to get
roughly the expectation value,
but you're going to get a
little plus minus uncertainty.
So you're going to all points
here in your measurement.
So this dashed thing
is your histogram
after doing lots of experiments.
You have lots of dots in here.
And roughly, this is
how it comes about.
It's not terribly precise
because I cannot put a point
either here, because if I
say the measurement was this,
I'm suggesting that I also
measured the momentum on that
state, or I could only
measure the position.
But it's a rough
idea, rough picture,
of how big the spread is here.
There is a mathematical
theory to do
this more precisely, although
physically not much clearer,
which are called
Wigner distributions.
I don't think it helps
too much to understand it,
but the rough picture
is relatively clear.
So if you divide by 1
over square root of 2,
this quantity that was equal
to d over square root of 2,
you get, in this scale plus
1/2 and minus 1/2, so 1, 1, 1,
and this value there.
There was a question there.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
again how the Gaussian relates
to the uncertainty [INAUDIBLE]?
BARTON ZWIEBACH:
So I don't know how
the Gaussian relates
to uncertainty in x.
So basically, we computed the
uncertainty in x for the ground
state, and I claimed that
for a coherent state,
the uncertainty in x cannot
change because you just took
the state and you moved it away.
And the uncertainty
of x doesn't talk
about what the
expectation value of x is.
That changes when
you move a state.
But just how much it's
spread and how much
the state is spread is not
changed by a translation.
So this is the old result for
the ground state uncertainty,
ground state uncertainty,
and neither is changed.
Let's go now into
our squeezed states.
So what are going to
be squeezed states?
They're going to be
pretty useful states.
They have lots of
applications nowadays.
They've been constructed
over the last 10 years
more and more often,
and people are now
able to construct what is called
squeezed states experimentally.
And the way we're
going to motivate it
is by imagining that you have a
harmonic oscillator, a particle
n, and some spring,
k, or an omega.
And there's a Hamiltonian.
H is equal to p squared over 2
m plus 1/2 m omega x squared.
But this Hamiltonian
is going to be
the Hamiltonian of a
particle that has mass m1,
and the oscillator
has frequency w1,
and that's what we're going
to call the first Hamiltonian.
After a little while, you
observe this Hamiltonian.
I will erase this thing.
We don't need them anymore.
We observe this thing and this
has an uncertainty, delta x,
proportional to-- we know this v
over square root of 2, so h bar
over 2 m1 omega 1.
And an uncertainty in
p, which is delta p
equals square root of h
bar m1 omega 1 over 2.
And again, they
saturate the bound
if you have your ground state.
So ground state is here.
These two uncertainties,
the bound is saturated,
all is good.
Nevertheless, suddenly,
at time equals
0, this state, this particle,
is in the ground state.
The Hamiltonian changes.
There's an abrupt
change in the physics.
Maybe the temperature
was changed
and the spring constant
changed, or the particle, a drop
was added to it and
its mass changed,
but the Hamiltonian has
changed all of a sudden.
So this Hamiltonian, H1,
is valid for H less than 0
and a particle in
the ground state.
So the particle's
in the ground state,
the Hamiltonian is fine there,
but suddenly, the Hamiltonian
changes.
The particle identity
has not changed.
The particle is there, but it
is the Hamilton that changes.
So there's an H2,
p squared over 2 m2
plus 1/2 m squared w
squared 2 x squared.
The picture is physically clean.
The particle is sitting
there in the ground state,
and suddenly, the parameters
of the system change.
So this particle was
having a good time,
it was at the ground
state, relaxed.
Then suddenly, the wave function
didn't change at time equals 0.
It was spread over
some distance.
No measurement
was done, nothing.
And suddenly, this
particle finds itself
with some wave function
but in another Hamiltonian.
From now on, its
time evolution is
going to be governed by
the second Hamiltonian.
Now, since the
second Hamiltonian
is different from the
first Hamiltonian,
this particle is not going to
be any more in the ground state.
Even though it was in the ground
state of the first Hamiltonian,
it's not anymore in the ground
state of the second Hamiltonian
as soon as the thing
gets turned on.
So for t greater than 0,
this Hamilton is there.
So actually, the wave
function does not change, so
let me write delta x, and I'll
write it the following way,
h bar over 2 m2 omega 1.
But you say, no,
delta x didn't change.
Correct.
So I'll put the factor
m2 w2 over m1 w1,
and now it's the same delta x.
Similarly, for delta
p, I will write
that this is square root
of h bar m2 omega 2 over 2,
and put the factor m1
omega 1 over m2 omega
2 in front in such
a way that it is
the same delta x and
the same delta p.
Now, delta x times delta p
multiply to be h bar over 2,
and they still
multiply to that number
because I didn't change them.
But this is equal-- I'll call
this number e to the minus
gamma.
I'll go to another blackboard.
Delta x is e to the minus
gamma times square root
of h bar over 2 m2 omega 2.
And delta p is e to
the gamma, because it's
the inverse factor
on the one that we
call gamma, square root of
h bar m2 omega 2 over 2,
where e to the gamma is
the square root of m1 omega
1 over m2 omega 2.
Look, we've done
very simple things.
We haven't done really much.
But already, we start
to see what's happening.
From the viewpoint of
the second Hamiltonian,
these uncertainties
are not right.
They are not the uncertainties
of the ground state,
because from the viewpoint
of the second Hamiltonian,
the ground state
uncertainty is this
and the ground state
uncertainty is this.
And indeed, this particle
was in the ground state,
it had some Gaussian,
but that's not
the right Gaussian for
the second Hamiltonian.
It's the right Gaussian
for the first Hamiltonian.
So it's not in the ground state
of the second Hamiltonian,
but it's in a particular state
in which, if gamma is positive,
the uncertainty in x is squeezed
from the lowest uncertainty
that you get in an
energy eigenstate.
And the uncertainty
and the momentum
will be stretched
in that direction.
So you see, in the ground state
of the harmonic oscillator,
you get that uncertainty, and
that's a canonical uncertainty.
But this uncertainty is
squeezed because it's
different from what it should
be, and this is squeezed.
So from the viewpoint of
the second Hamiltonian,
the ground state of
the first Hamiltonian
is a squeezed state.
It's a staple
whose uncertainties
have been squeezed.
And those states
exist, and the purpose
of what we're going
to do now is try
to determine them, find
them, see what they are,
how they behave.
Any questions?
Yes, Nicholas?
AUDIENCE: I'm a
little confused why
we can say that delta x
[INAUDIBLE] these new ones are
just related to the old
ones by this factor.
BARTON ZWIEBACH: OK.
You see, what I assumed is
that before time equals 0,
you had a Gaussian.
That was the original Gaussian.
That was the original
wave function,
and you had some delta
x and some delta p that
were given by this
one [INAUDIBLE].
Now, I didn't do anything except
rewrite the same quantities
here, because what
I said next was
that even though
at time equals 0,
the Hamiltonian changes,
the wave function
doesn't change.
The wave function
remains the same.
After that time,
it's going to start
changing because the new
Hamiltonian kicks in.
But this delta x's
are the same as
that I wrote, and
here are the same.
But here, you see clearly
that this delta x with respect
to the second Hamiltonian
is not the one
that it would be if
it would be a ground
state, nor the delta p.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Just at the instant
you change the Hamiltonian,
because they might
have all [INAUDIBLE],
the uncertainties would change.
BARTON ZWIEBACH: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Is this just
at the instant where
we change the Hamiltonian,
because after some time,
the wave function might
change [INAUDIBLE].
BARTON ZWIEBACH: That's right.
This is just after I
change the Hamiltonian.
The time evolution of
this state is something
that we have to
figure out later.
But after I've changed
the Hamiltonian,
the state looks squeezed.
So how can we calculate and
understand these things?
So the way to think of
this is the following.
You see, you have this
system of two Hamiltonians.
There's an x and a p operator,
and the second Hamiltonian
has an x and a p operator.
These are the properties
of the particles.
Therefore, what that
I'm going to think of
is that the x and
the p operators
are the operators that
describe the particle.
They are unchanged
because we're talking
about this same
object, same particle.
So if I have the x operator,
which is equal to this formula,
h bar over 2 m1 omega 1 a1
dagger plus a1 like this.
From the first
Hamiltonian, the x's
are related to a1's
and a1 daggers,
but this is the same x
describing the same position
as you would do in the
second Hamiltonian.
So m2 w2 a2 hat
plus a2 hat dagger.
It's a very strong physical
assumption I'm making here.
It's an assumption that's
so strong that in many ways,
you could almost say,
well, I'll buy it,
but we'll see if it gives
something reasonable.
I'm saying the x operator
is really the same thing,
and you could view
it as constructed
from ingredients of
the first Hamiltonian
or the second Hamiltonian.
So is the p operator.
p, which is-- well, I
have a formula here--
minus i m1 omega 1 h bar
over 2 a1 minus a1 dagger--
should be the same as
minus i m2 omega 2 h bar
over 2 a2 minus a2 dagger.
So x and p are not changing.
We're not talking about
two particles that
have an x1 and a p1, and
the second particle, an x2
and a p2.
It's just one particle
has an x and a p
is what you observe when
you measure position
and you observe when
you measure momentum.
Nevertheless, x and p
are related in this way
to the creation and
annihilation operators.
So we're going to find from
this some very strange relation
between the creation
operators, the annihilation
operators of the first
system and the second system.
So what do we get, in fact?
Well, the constants disappear
from the first equation
roughly, and you get a1
dagger is equal to-- you
get the ratio of m1
omega 1 over m2 omega 2,
so you get e to the gamma
a1 a2 plus a2 dagger.
From the bottom one,
a1 minus a1 dagger
is equal to e to the minus
gamma a2 minus a2 dagger.
These two equations
give you that.
It should be clear.
You just cancel the
constants and remember
the definition of
e to the gamma.
And now we can solve
for a1 and a1 dagger
in terms of a2 and a2 dagger.
And what do we find?
a1 is equal to a2 cosh gamma
plus a2 dagger sinch gamma,
and the dagger is what
you would imagine.
So a1 dagger is equal
to a2 dagger cosh
gamma plus a2 sinch gamma.
The second equation
that you can calculate
is the dagger of the first.
It should be that.
And now you've
found the scrambling
of the creation,
annihilation operators.
The old annihilation
operator is a mixture
of the new annihilation operator
and a creation operator.
They're mixed.
It's a very strange
thing that has happened,
a mixture between creation
and annihilation operators.
This is so famous in
physics, it has a name.
It's called the
Bogoliubov transformation.
It appears in the analysis
of black hole radiation.
There's a Bogoliubov
transformation
between the fields far
away of the black hole
and the fields near
the black hole.
It appears everywhere.
And here it has
appeared, so we're
going to try to understand
what it does for us.
Similarly, you can
find what a2 is
in terms of a1's by the
symmetry of these equations.
This corresponds to
actually letting gamma
go to minus gamma, because
if you pass these gammas
to the other side, the
equations are of the same form.
By letting 1 become 2,
2 becomes 1 and gamma
goes to minus gamma.
So we don't need it right
now, but in case you
want to find the other ones,
the 2's in terms of the 1's, you
would just change the sign of
gamma and it would work out.
So this relation is the key to
allow you to calculate things.
So what do we want to calculate?
Well, here is what I
would like to calculate.
The ground state of
the first oscillator
is this thing we had.
It's the thing that
has the wave function.
But I want to express it as
a superposition of states
of the second oscillator
because the second oscillator is
what gives you the
new Hamiltonian
and what's going to tell
you how the state is
going to evolve later.
So presumably, this state is
some number times the ground
state of the second
oscillator, plus maybe
some creation operator on
the second vacuum as well
with a constant.
Now, this wave function of
the ground state is even,
and I would expect that
it's a superposition of even
eigenstates of the second
oscillator as well.
And even eigenstates
are things that
have even occupation numbers.
Those are the even
Hermite polynomials.
So presumably, it goes
like this and things
with four oscillators
and things like that.
So what that after is
this sort of expression
of the original state in terms
of energy eigenstates in terms
of anything of the
second oscillator.
So how can we do that?
Well, one thing we
know about this state
is that a1 [? on it ?]
is equal to 0.
It's killed by a1, but that
a1 is an interesting thing.
It's a2 cosh gamma plus
a2 dagger sinch gamma,
and that thing must
kill that state.
So I could at least, if I had
infinite time, put a few terms
and try to calculate more
or less what kind of state
is killed by this strange
combination of creation
and annihilation operators.
You see, we know
a ground state is
killed by the normal
annihilation operator.
That's what this is.
But this operator,
now we know it's
given by this
formula over there,
and then it must kill all that.
So we're faced with a problem
that is in principle fairly
difficult, and you could not
hope for an except solution
unless there's something
very nice going on.
Happily, squeezed states
are still very nice
and tractable states, so
let's see what we can do.
Well, what I'm going to
do is to put an ansatz
for this state based on this
expansion that I had there.
I would say, look, there's going
to be a normalization constant,
but at the end of the
day, we have things acting
on the vacuum, so there's
going to be something very
messy acting on the vacuum of 2.
And what is that going to be?
Well, we've learned about
coherent states that
are exponentials of
oscillators, exponentials
of a's and a daggers added.
So here, we're going
to attempt something
a little more general.
I'll put an exponential minus
1/2, and what should I put?
Well, let's try to be
simple minded still.
It seems to go in even power,
so if we're very lucky,
maybe we can put just an
a2 dagger a2 dagger here,
an exponential something
quadratic in oscillators.
And I don't know what the
coefficient is in front,
and it may depend
on gamma because I
have to solve an
equation with gamma.
So I'll put minus 1/2
f of gamma times that.
And we'll see if
we can solve this.
So what does it
mean to solve it?
Well, it means that it must be
annihilated by this operator.
So our computations with the
creation and annihilation
operators are becoming
more and more complicated.
They look more and
more complicated.
They're really not harder.
Let's see what happens.
So I need now that a2 cosh
gamma plus a2 dagger sinch gamma
kill this state.
So the N is going to go outside.
It's a number.
So acting on e to the
minus 1/2 f of gamma a2
dagger a2 dagger on the
vacuum sub 2, that must be 0.
How does one solve this?
Well, let's see what we have.
Let's see this term.
a2 dagger, good.
a2 dagger commutes
with a2 dagger,
so I can bring the a2 dagger
all the way to the right
and it doesn't kill the vacuum,
so I don't gain anything.
Can be to the right or
to the left because it
commutes with this whole thing,
so I haven't gained anything
if I move it, so false start.
I don't want to move that one.
This one, I want
to leave it here,
and this one
somehow must produce
something that cancels this one.
Now, a2, on the other
hand, is the kind of thing
that always should be dealt with
because this is an annihilator
and that does kill that.
So as it moves along,
it encounters obstacles,
but obstacles are opportunities
because an obstacle means
we're going to get something
that maybe cancels that.
So if it also went through
and killed the vacuum,
we're finished.
This doesn't kill the vacuum.
Happily, it gets stuck here.
Now the thing that
we have to hope
is that we can disentangle
that commutator.
Now, here is a universal thing.
How do I want to write this?
I'm going to write it like this.
I have an a2, a
number, I don't care
about the number, and
a complicated thing,
and a vacuum.
Whenever you have an a,
any operator, and a vacuum,
this is equal to a
commutator with the operator
on the vacuum.
That should be second
nature because this is even
given to that minus oa, but
oa, the a is near to the vacuum
and it kills it.
So whenever you
have an a o vacuum,
you can put the commutator,
so I'll do that here.
So I put a2, the cosh
gamma, I take it out.
I put this whole thing minus
1/2 f a dagger a dagger 2.
This whole thing and the vacuum.
That's the first term.
And the second term, I
have to just copy it.
Sinch gamma a2 dagger
e to the minus 1/2 fa
squared dagger on the vacuum.
All that should be 0.
So what do we get?
Is that commutator
doable or undoable?
It's happily a
simple commutator,
even if it doesn't look
like it, because whenever
you see a commutator like
that, you think A to the B,
and then you know
if you're in luck,
this is just AB e to
the B, and this is true
if AB commutes with
B. So that's what
you must think whenever
you see these things.
Do mind this lucky situation.
Yes, you are, because
with this commutator,
one a will kill an
a dagger, so you
will be left with an dagger.
But a dagger commutes with b,
which is a dagger a dagger.
So AB, A with B is
just add an a dagger up
to a function or a number, and
then a dagger commutes with B
so you are in good shape.
This is true.
So what do we get here?
We get cosh gamma,
and then we just
get the commutator
of a2 with minus 1/2
f a2 dagger a2 dagger times
the whole exponential--
I won't write it-- times
the vacuum plus sinch times
a2 dagger times the whole
exponential times the vacuum.
We have to do this commutator,
but the f doesn't matter.
It's a constant.
It's a function.
No operator in there. a2
with a2 daggers are 1.
There are two of
them, so you get a 2,
and the 1/2 cancels this,
so you get minus cosh gamma
f a2 dagger times
the exponential plus,
from the other term, sinch gamma
a2 dagger times the exponential
on the vacuum equals 0.
And, as promised, we were good.
We get an a2 dagger, a2 dagger.
These two terms cancel if f
is equal to tan hyperbolic
of gamma, which is
sine over cosine
so that these two things cancel.
I can write this, of course, as
minus cosh gamma f plus sinch
gamma a2 dagger, the
exponential, and the vacuum,
equals 0.
So it's just a simple
relation, but there we go.
Tanh gamma is the thing.
Tanh gamma gives you
the answer, and let
me write this state
so that you enjoy it.
Let's see.
The state is just a
fairly interesting thing,
this 01 expressed in the new
Hilbert space of the second
oscillator is some n of gamma
times the exponential of minus
1/2 tangent hyperbolic
of gamma a2 dagger,
a2 dagger on the vacuum sub 2.
And you need the
normalization, n of gamma,
and it will be done.
Now, the normalization,
you may say well, look,
normalizations are good things.
Sometimes, you work without
normalizations and you're OK,
but it turns out that these
normalizations are pretty
useful, and unless you get
them, some calculations
are kind of undoable.
So it's a little
bit of a challenge
to get that normalization.
You can try in several ways.
The most naive way
is to say, well, this
must have unit
norms, so n squared,
and then I take the bra of
this and the ket of that,
so it would be a vacuum,
an exponential of minus 1/2
tangent a a, and an
exponential of minus 1/2
tangent a dagger, a dagger.
Must be 1.
n squared times that.
The problem is that I've never
been able to compute this.
At least it takes a
long time and you get it
by indirect methods, but
getting a number out of this
is painful.
So there's one way of getting
the normalization here
that is not so bad.
It's a little
surprising what you do.
You do the following.
You declare, I'm
going to compute
the overlap of 2, the vacuum
of 2, with the vacuum of 1.
And now, what is this,
n gamma vacuum of 2
here, e to the minus 1/2 tanh
gamma a2 dagger a2 dagger
vacuum of 2.
How difficult is it to
compute this inner product?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BARTON ZWIEBACH: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Not difficult.
BARTON ZWIEBACH: Not difficult.
What is it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
BARTON ZWIEBACH:
Yeah, that thing.
AUDIENCE: e to the
negative 1/2 tanh gamma.
It's 1.
BARTON ZWIEBACH: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: I mean, you
multiply the a2 dagger right
across to the left
hand side of the ket.
BARTON ZWIEBACH: Yeah,
you're saying it, indeed.
Look, this thing is
as simple as can be.
This is just 1.
Why is that so?
You expand the exponential,
and you have 1 plus things,
but all the things
have a daggers.
Now, a daggers
don't kill this 1,
but they killed the
other 1 on the left,
and there's nothing obstructing
them from reaching the left,
so this is 1.
It's completely
different from this one
because if you expand this one,
the a daggers kill the thing
but there's lots
of a's to the left.
And the a's want to
get here, but there's
lots of a daggers to the
right, so this is hard,
but this is easy.
So n of gamma is 0 2 0 1.
But what is that?
If you introduce a complete
set of position states, zx,
This is 0 2 x x 0 1.
This one is the ground
state wave function
of the first
Hamiltonian, and this
is the start of the
ground state wave
function of the
second Hamiltonian.
And those you know
because you know m, omega.
You know the ground
state wave functions,
so this integral can be done.
So this whole normalization
is given by this integral,
and this integral gives you 1
over square root of cosh gamma.
That interval takes
a few lines to make,
but the end result is there.
So you got your coherent states.
You got now the squeezed
state completely normalized,
so let's write it out.
0 1 is equal to 1 over square
root of cosh gamma exponential
of minus 1/2 tanh gamma a2
dagger a2 dagger on the vacuum
sub 2.
Wow.
That's it.
That's a squeeze state that
has been squeezed in such a way
that the squeezing
parameter appears here
in the exponential.
Now, this is the
way we got to it,
but now I wanted to just think
of it independently, just
from the beginning.
If you had a Hamiltonian,
this is an interesting state
all in itself because
it is a squeezed state.
It's a Gaussian, but of the
wrong shape for this system.
This is a Gaussian of the
right shape for system two.
But once you put all
these oscillators,
it's not anymore a
Gaussian of the right type.
It's a squeezed Gaussian.
So if we forget about
this system one,
let me write this thing from
the beginning and say like this.
We have a Hamiltonian,
we have a ground state,
we have m and omega, and
we have a and a dagger.
Let's just define what we call
the squeezed vacuum, vacuum sub
gamma, to be
precisely this thing.
1 over square root of cosh
gamma exponential of minus 1/2
tanh gamma a dagger
a dagger, not 2
anymore because we have
just a single system.
A single system, the
ground state, and now we've
defined this state, which
is what we had there before,
but we don't think of
it anymore as, oh, it
came from some
other Hamiltonian,
but rather, this is
a state on its own.
It's a squeezed vacuum state.
And from the computations
that we did here,
the delta x for this state would
be e to the minus gamma h bar m
omega.
and m omega over here.
So these are these,
and you don't
need to know what gamma is.
That's a number that
somebody chose for you.
Any number that
you want is gamma,
and therefore, you use
it to squeeze the state.
And that's what you've achieved.
So you have a Hamiltonian
of a harmonic oscillator.
You can construct the vacuum.
You know how to
construct coherent states
by acting on the vacuum.
Now you know how to construct
squeezed states, states
in which the expectation
values do those things.
We had a very nice formula
where we began the lecture today
in which the coherent
state was just
a unitary operator
acting on the vacuum.
Now, we made sure
to normalize this,
so we did check in
this calculation
that o gamma 0
gamma is equal to 1.
So this thing must
come from the action
of some unitary operator
acting on the vacuum.
Which is that unitary operator
that acts on the vacuum
and gives you that?
Not so easy to find.
All the computations here
are a little challenging,
as you've seen.
But here's the answer.
Cosh gamma e to the exponential
of minus 1/2 tanh gamma
a dagger a dagger
should be something
like an e to the what?
Should be something
like e to the a dagger
a dagger minus aa
acting on the vacuum.
Why?
Because certainly, the aa's
are going to disappear,
and you're going to get
products of this one squared.
And this is anti-Hermitian,
so that operator is unitary,
but I now must put the
gamma somewhere there.
So what should I put here in
order to get that to work?
Well, it's maybe
something you can
try by assuming gamma is very
small and expanding both sides,
or finding a differential
equation, or doing things,
but the answer is
incredibly simple.
It's e to the minus
just gamma over 2.
That's it.
Gamma appears here,
and by the time
you reorder this
quadratic form--
you see, what you have
to do here is expand,
and then you have
powers of these,
and then you have to bring all
the annihilators to the right
and kill them.
And then you have a power
series in squares of this thing.
That will reassemble
into this exponential.
It's almost a miracle
that something
like that could happen,
but it does happen.
And it's a very interesting
calculation, actually,
to do that.
We don't do it in the course.
I may post some pages that
I did once this computation.
And that is a nice operator.
We call it the
squeezing operator.
So s of gamma is a unitary
operator, s of gamma.
The squeezed state of
0 gamma is equal to s
of gamma on the vacuum
where s of gamma
is equal to e to the minus
gamma over 2 a dagger a dagger
minus aa, that operator.
It's a unitary operator
and it does the squeezing.
Actually, once you have squeezed
states, you can do more things,
and you can squeeze
and then translate.
Those are the most
general states
that people use
in quantum optics.
So you take a vacuum, you
squeeze it with s of gamma,
and then you translate
it with v of alpha.
And this is the state,
alpha gamma, squeeze factor,
translation factor.
One picture of that
is in our alpha plane.
You take the vacuum that
is some spherical ball here
in the x expectation
value, p expectation value.
You squeeze it.
You might decide, I don't
want to have too much delta x,
so you squeeze it and you
produce something like this.
That's a squeezed vacuum
by the time you apply this.
And then you do the alpha,
and you translate it out,
and this state is now
going to start rotating
and doing all kinds of motion.
It's pretty practical stuff.
Actually, some of you
are taking junior lab,
and the person that works
a lot there in junior lab
is Nergis Mavalvala, and she
does gravity wave detection,
and squeezed states has
been exactly what she's
been working.
In order to minimize
displacements
in the gravity wave
detectors, they
have a squeeze vacuum state
injected into the detector
to make the harmonic
oscillator that
represents the mirror stabilize
its uncertainty in position
to the maximum possible.
There's a whole
fabulous technique
that people use with
the squeezed states.
Now, the squeezed
states allow you
to construct some states that
seemed to us that they were
pretty strange and that we never
had good formulas for them.
So that's how I want to
conclude the lecture.
I will leave photon
states for next time,
but I want to discuss
one more application
of the squeezed states,
and this comes from limits.
So here is your squeezed
state, e to the minus gamma.
So let's squeeze the
state to the end.
Take gamma to go to infinity.
What happens to
the squeezed state?
So you're narrowing out the
ground state in position space
to the maximum possible.
What happens to the state?
Well, it goes a little singular,
but not terribly singular.
Gamma is going to
infinity, so cosh
is going to infinity as well.
So the state is going kind
of to 0, but 0 sub infinity.
It's proportional, but
the exponential is good.
Exponential of minus
1/2 tangent of gamma
as gamma goes to
infinity is just 1.
And this is a dagger a
dagger on the vacuum.
This state is in almost
terrible danger to be infinite.
If you try to find
its wave function,
you're not going to be
able to normalize it.
You've reached the
end of the road
kind of thing because of this.
Gamma goes to infinity.
This is going to
be infinite here
because this state,
if you compute
its overlap with
itself, is blowing up.
And here, you see
the niceness of this.
It also suggests that gamma
can go from plus infinity
to minus infinity, and
that's a natural thing.
Nevertheless, here, it goes
from plus 1 to minus 1.
If you had a number 3
here, this is a state
that blows much worse
than the worst delta
function or derivative or
square that you've ever had.
It's just unbelievably
divergent because it just
can't exist, this state.
You're going beyond infinity
here to go behind this thing.
So it's just pretty
much impossible.
So the limit is
states are reasonable
as long as this quadratic
form goes from minus 1 to 1.
And when you go to 1, you get
this, and what should this be?
This should be the
wave function I
associated to a delta function.
This would be the position
state, x equals 0.
Roughly, it's a delta function.
And indeed, if you
act with x on it,
x, remember, is a plus a dagger.
Act on this exponential.
Now, do you remember
how to do that?
This a dagger doesn't do
anything but the a goes here,
and it's a trivial commutator.
You get minus a dagger.
So it actually kills
this and gives you 0.
So in fact, the exposition
operator acting on here
gives you 0.
It looks like it is really
the state x equals 0.
If you go the other way
around, and you take gamma
to be minus infinity, the
only thing that changes here
is the sign.
So this is like the delta of
x, or the x equals 0 state.
And if you take 0 minus
infinity, goes like x minus 1/2
plus 1/2 a dagger a
dagger on the vacuum.
And this state is a delta
function in momentum.
It's the momentum
state p equals 0.
Why?
Because gamma is going
to minus infinity.
The uncertainty of
momentum is going to 0.
And therefore, indeed, if
you act with the momentum
operator on this
state, it's like acting
with a minus a
dagger, and you've
changed the sign of this, but
you've changed the sign here,
so it also kills this state.
So it looks like we can really
construct position and momentum
eigenstates now with
squeezed states,
and that's what they
are supposed to be.
A squeezed state is something
that has been squeezed enough
that you can get
a delta function.
So how do you finish
that construction?
Here is the claim.
Square root of 2 m omega over
h bar x a dagger minus 1/2
a dagger a dagger
acting on the vacuum.
This is the claim, that this
is the x position state.
So basically, you have
to squeeze first and then
translate this thing
to the exposition.
So how do you check this?
Well, you should check
that the x operator, which
is something times a plus a
dagger acting on this thing
gives you little x.
So you should have that
x operator on this thing
gives you x x.
And that is going to work out
because the a dagger is going
to sit here and it's going
to get canceled with the a
with this, but the
a with this part
is just going to bring down
an x with the right factor.
So this state, which is a
squeezed state and a little bit
of a coherent state as well,
is producing the position
eigenstate.
In the harmonic
oscillator, you can really
construct the
position eigenstate
and you can calculate
the normalization.
The normalization comes out
to be a rather simple thing.
So at the end of the day,
the position eigenstate
is m omega over pi h bar to the
1/4 e to the minus m omega x
squared over 2h bar.
And this whole
exponential, square root
of 2 m omega over h bar,
x a dagger minus 1/2
a dagger a dagger
acting on the vacuum.
So your basis of creation
and annihilation operators
on the harmonic oscillator
is flexible enough
to allow for a concrete
description of your position
eigenstates, and a
tractable one as well.
And that's the extreme
limit of squeezing, together
with some little bit of
coherent displacement.
Next time, we'll do
our photon states
and we'll illustrate the
ideas of both coherent
and squeezed states
at the same time.